[Music]  oh  i can't see you shake my hand  [Music]  my grandmother was right the boogeyman  was real  it's over we can't hurt anyone ever  again  no one told you told me what  somebody in there  [Music]  michael myers  stop you had a knife in your stomach you  and allison  should not have to keep running evil  dies tonight  [Music]  i'm not just gonna sit and watch another  innocent person die  if you track michael's victims it's a  straight line  to michael's childhood home  what do we do we fight  let's hunt him down  michael myers is flesh and blood  but a man couldn't have survived that  fire  the more he kills the more he transcends  run go now he's the essence of evil  [Music]  do it  you want your math come and get it  i'm coming for you michael  you